I was quite young there was only eight i
remember my dad's friends children had a
playstation I remember when they played
Laura Croft I hadn't seen a girl in the
lead character in a video game she was
extremely fierce and determined capable
and the adventurer I've been dreaming
since I was a kid be part in the big
action adventure to push myself and in
this film I really came to do
[Music]
all stories very much an origin story
setting Croft little beginning she's
regular girl living in East London
here's the part she's seen her dad so
she goes out and an adventure to see if
he's still out there didn't come here
I'm glad that you did this film is about
her becoming the action here that we
know her to be when it comes to the
action Alicia as a beast you have to see
her in this movie man she's just a
winning combination you know she's been
training hard Fight Club while work
water work shootouts chases it's
relentless I was amazed by what she went
through she gets beaten up all day long
bruises and the hit you can
suck up but the cold that is the tough
thing when you reach hypothermia level
so we had water Catherines being thrown
at us you fly right in the middle of
them we've even had to reshoot some
things as I turn to blue and I can't fix
that on screen I wanted her to be a
strong physical girl so I started to
gain muscle and gain strength
she's just a real powerhouse she made me
embarrassed to take my shirt off and I
go to the gym five days a week it's been
a very physical adventure Felicia has
impressed me a lot
the first time we've seen her lead an
action movie and she's making this bull
by the horns a lot of passion for
adventure she gets it but she stands up
again
was gonna have the big sets and the
mystical doors being open always wanted
to try all these mystical action beats I
do like I had the strength to do it
what's your name Laura surname Croft
Barry
your father's gone you can pick up where
he left off I see so much of him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tomb for the mother
of death if Trinity succeeds our world
is in danger promise me you will stop I
promise I think I know where my dad went
that's right in the middle of the devil
sea it will be an adventure death isn't
a hotter than adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here
but I'm glad that you did
[Music]
what do you know about my father now I
see the lightness the recklessness close
the to once and for the fate of humanity
is now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days
the world has gone bloody mad I'll take
two
[Music]